aujourd'hui les produits biologiques
font de plus en plus partie du paysage
mais ça n'a pas toujours été le cas pour
se lancer en production de lait
biologique il y a trente ans il fallait
être audacieux voyez l'histoire de
producteurs qui ont misé gros et qui
récoltent aujourd'hui le succès
[Musique]
moi
chaque jour même ingrédient même étape
il faut couper et goûter passer au
moulin salit on transforme environ 10%
de la production de lait biologique du
québec les québécois et les canadiens
ressentent le besoin encore plus
qu'avant d'acheter des produits qui sont
faites en amont en harmonie avec
l'environnement
[Musique]
à la fromagerie l'ancêtre de bécancour
quelques 50 employés transforme 6
millions de litres de lait biologique
par année 500 à 600 mille kilos de
fromage et presqu'autant demeure la plus
importante entreprise du genre au pays
[Musique]
trente ans après le grand démarrage
l'entreprise a trouvé sa place sur le
marché un marché de niche quand on sait
que le lait biologique représente à
peine 1,5 pour cent du volume produit au
canada
à l'époque il y avait aucun moyen de
commercialiser le lait biologique
tout le lait à les mélanger avec les
conventionnels pour contrer ce problème
les agriculteurs vont prendre une
décision qui va tout changer
ils seront non seulement producteurs
laitiers biologiques mais aussi
transformateurs l'histoire débute au
tournant des années 90 neuf familles du
centre du québec dont celle de madeleine
désilets et de son mari germain décide
de faire le saut en production laitière
biologique
un pari audacieux les bains ont pris des
gants à risque parce que c'était
vraiment nouveau pas vraiment d'études
août chef de fête l'assumer y était
confiant que c'était la méthode la venue
l'heure des changements majeurs vers la
transition biologique c'est le grand air
le troupeau passe l'essentiel de son
temps à l'extérieur au pâturage
entre mi-novembre madeleine c'est elle
qui a amené vraiment le questionnement
sur la façon de faire l'agriculture puis
là-bas on a dit au moyen de faire
autrement
faire autrement ça veut dire amener les
animaux au pâturage mais surtout arrêter
l'utilisation des pesticides et engrais
chimiques pour préserver la qualité
naturelle du seul et prolonger la vie
des vaches en production de mauvaises
habitudes faire des dix arrosage piqué
tape une mauvaise herbe et ses bas on
s'habitue quand on comprend pourquoi
qu'on fait fall être interdit ce cd des
opportunités dans la vie mais fortis
faut qu'ils prennent des opportunités
[Musique]
à l'époque tout est à faire
le québec compte seulement 15 famille
productrice de lait biologique dont les
neuf fondatrice de l'ancêtre
[Musique]
et le ministère de l'agriculture du
québec n'a pas encore réglementé
l'appellation biologique
il le fera dix ans plus tard on allait à
contre-courant
il y en a beaucoup qui nous regardent la
libye avait pas le goût de nous suffit
je suis attendez pour voir qu'est ce
qu'on ferait comment que ça tournerait
notre faim tu ramènes décision qui
menait au temps de la tête que du carl
louis fleurant et producteur laitier à
nicolet il fait partie des familles
fondatrices
à l'époque il joue gros c'est lui qui
tient les rênes du fleuron familiale de
cinquième génération
il y avait un grand désir d'autonomie
puis avait aussi une question de santé
pourtant déjà reçues la naissance de son
premier fils à accélérer sa réflexion
désormais les produits chimiques n'ont
plus leur place sur sa ferme mais
s'affranchir c'est s'exposer à la
critique
il va se casser la gueule il va se
planter vie propos vivre de tous il va
faire n'importe quoi et on se bat et
environs pas assez d'argent pour mettre
de l'engrais chimique où ils sont en
difficulté ou sont fous il a donc fallu
s'organiser sans expertise des géants de
l'industrie et affronter l'inconnu en
achetant rien personnes venues
conseiller c'est facile à tort ou à
raison d'instiguer l'a pas reçue six
spots est le produit star pas de
lendemain ça pousse aux puces ou est
envahi par les mauvaises herbes sur
ledit mode super de mon entreprise même
où j'y croyais et je vais passer de la
peur de l'échec à la confiance de
réussie
j'ai de la misère à quoi avec la nature
est imparfaite au point il faut toute la
modifie moi je pense qu on la comprend
mal on l'a 16 mâles puis on al'avantage
aller plus loin dans sa coopération
le produit par be you doit développer
une expertise en cultures fourragères
aujourd'hui après plusieurs ajustements
dans leur alimentation
les quarante vaches de louis fleurs en
nourrice 100% bio produisent 10 mille
litres de lait par année légèrement
au-dessus de la moyenne provinciale
l'autre volet crucial c'est le soin aux
animaux
le mot d'ordre ici la prévention louis
fleurs en fait tout pour éviter les
antibiotiques les visites du vétérinaire
sont plus rares et ses patientes ne sont
plaint pas l'éleveur a sa propre
pharmacie de la lhouest pour la
digestion des huiles essentielles pour
les inflammations de la phytothérapie
pour le tennis se déploie dû accepter en
habitude de loger qu' aucun produit
synthèse qui sont complu dans ses
produits normés ma vie dans la marge et
[Rires]
tous les efforts consacrés à
l'alimentation et aux soins des animaux
ont permis d'allonger la vie des vaches
en production de 18 mois en moyenne un
progrès énorme aux yeux du producteur
ces succès ont convaincu son fils pierre
luc agronome de prendre la relève
son autre fils félix il songe aussi les
fronts se mettent au bio c'est dommage
on prenait ce qui se passe chez vous
plier vous avez donc bannir les aime
toutes
ils sont intrigués beau des questions
puis l'ouverture beaucoup plus grand je
pense qu'avant mais malgré les succès
certain jour se sont révélés plus
sombres particulièrement dans les
premières années
ça prenait de l'argent pour la semaine
suivante parce que sinon en étant
appelés à fermer les banques commencent
à être plus nerveuse j'ai fait que là
c'était le tour de table
ça prend un accent mis le kiki qui prime
est mon père avait dit baptiste que vous
voulez mon jouet à mettre le reste ça
avait été ça c'était réglé
on a en déjà assez convaincu que qu'on
avait la bonne entreprise s'il
s'agissait juste de lui donner le temps
de se développer puis de prendre racine
aujourd'hui 70% de la production de la
fromagerie l'ancêtre est exportée dans
les provinces canadiennes des neuf
producteurs laitiers fondateur cinq sont
toujours en production
leurs six ans d'âge en lactation sont
est suffisante pour répondre à la
demande
la fromagerie doit s'alimenter auprès
d'autres producteurs laitiers
biologiques du québec
on vise à transformer le maximum de lait
biologique qui se fait au québec plus
d'un quart nationaliser partout au pays
parce qu'elle détenait a de grandes
ambitions mais il fait face à une grave
pénurie de main d'oeuvre
son frère est confronté aux mêmes enjeux
qui toucherait encore plus durement le
secteur bio le plus de travail un peu
refusé qu'un plus l'intervention de
personnes ou d'avoir des animaux qui
vont pâturages je présume seulement pour
les ramener sa partie tranquille même
surtout
[Musique]
progressez puis une grande fierté à
nîmes madeleine désole quand elle voit
sa petite fille claudine 17 ans étudier
dans le domaine à fons pascal à aller un
peu cet esprit l'eau ne sont pas de
force de vouloir le couturier lui aussi
de systèmes d'impression
puis ce jeu nous avons mon parent qui se
lèvent le matin qui sera l'étape je
pense qu'il est vraiment passionné de
tupi ça m'a comme instauré à me dire je
suis la seule relève
pourquoi que j'essayerai pauvre malgré
moi ça n'a pas toujours été aussi un
modèle pour moi le gars m'a vraiment
beaucoup inspiré la base
[Musique]